NOW AS EVERYONE KNOWS OR SHOULD
KNOW, THIS SUNDAY IS MOTHER'S
DAY, RIGHT?
WITHOUT A DOUBT, WITHOUT A
DOUBT, THE MOST IMPORTANT DAY OF
THE YEAR.
MY MOM WATCHES.
NO, IT IS IMPORTANT.
HERE'S WHAT WE DID.
WE SENT OUT OUR "NIGHTLY SHOW"
SPECIAL CONTRIBUTOR LAVELL
CRAWFORD TO SEE HOW PEOPLE ON
THE STREETS OF NEW YORK WERE
PREPPING FOR THE BIG DAY.
>> HI, THIS IS LAVELL CRAWFORD
FOR "THE NIGHTLY SHOW," AND
MOTHER'S DAY IS AM CATEGORY UP.
I'M A MOMMA'S BOY, AND I'M
TRYING TO SEE WHO ELSE
LOVES THEIR MOMMA.
SO I'M IN NEW YORK RIGHT NOW TO
FIND OUT, "DO YOU LOVE YOUR
MOMMA?"
WHAT ARE YOU GETTING YOUR MOTHER
FOR MOTHER'S DAY?
>> FLOWERS, CHOCOLATES.
>> FLOWERS AND CHOCOLATES?
YOU AND YOUR MOMMA DON'T HAVE A
GOOD RELATIONSHIP.
>> I DO EVERYTHING FOR MY
MOTHER?
>> OH, YEAH TAKE A BULLET.
MOTHER, MOTHER, MOTHER, MOTHER,
I LOVE MOTHERS.
YOU KNOW, I THINK THEY'RE THE
GREATEST.
THEY'RE THE FRUIT OF THE TREE.
THEY'RE THE FRUIT OF LIFE.
>> THAT'S WHAT THEY TOLD ME, BUT
I DON'T KNOW IF I BELIEVE IT.
>> IN THREE WORDS NAME-- GIVE
ME-- GIVE ME YOUR BEST
DESCRIPTION OF YOUR MOTHER.
>> SHE'S STRONG.
SHE'S INDEPENDENT.
AND SHE'S ARTISTIC.
>> YOU WANT TO KNOW MY THREE
WORDS ABOUT MY MOMMA?
BETTER THAN YOURS.
MY MOMMA CAN KICK YOUR MOMMA'S
ASS ANY DAY.
OH, IS SHE HERE?
HI!
I DIDN'T KNOW IF SHE WAS HERE.
I APOLOGIZE.
SHE WAS TALKING-- YOU DIDN'T
HEAR WHAT SHE SAID ABOUT MY
MOMMA.
FOR REAL.
WHAT DID YOUR DAUGHTER GET YOU?
WHAT WAS THE NICEST GIFT
SHE EVER GOT YOU?
>> THIS TIFFANY'S BRACELET.
>> I LOVE IT!
WHAT HAVE YOU GOTTEN YOUR MOTHER
FOR MOTHER'S DAY?
>> IT'S NOT THE MATERIAL THINGS,
I THINK THE BEST GIFT YOU CAN
GET--
>> YOU'RE FULL OF CRAP.
>> MY DAUGHTER WAS SUPPOSED TO
MEET ME TODAY BECAUSE I'M GOING
TO MY DENTIST.
SHE IS GOING TO A GALA DINNER.
>> WHAT IS HER NAME?
>> VICKI.
>> VICKI, WHERE ARE YOU?
WHERE ARE YOU, VICKI?
YOUR MOMMA IS TALKING TO A
STRANGE BLACK MAN BECAUSE SHE
DON'T HAVE NOTHING TO DO BECAUSE
YOU DIDN'T WANT TO COME AND TAKE
HER TO THE DENTIST.
DESCRIBE YOUR MOMMA IN THREE
WORDS.
>> BEAUTIFUL, STRONG,
RESPONSIBLE.
>> LET ME JUST DESCRIBE MY MOMMA
TO YOU.
>> WHAT.
>> BETTER THAN YOURS.
>> I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT.
>> MY MOMMA KICK YOUR MOMMA'S
ASS
>> I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT.
>> YOUR MOMMA HERE?
>> RIGHT OVER THERE.
>> IS THIS GRANDMA?
( APPLAUSE )
LOOK IN THE CAMERA AND TELL YOUR
MOMMA HOW SPECIAL SHE IS TO YOU.
>> HI, MOM.
I LOVE YOU SO MUCH, AND THANKS
FOR EVERYTHING THAT YOU HAVE
DONE FOR ME, AND I'M A MOMMA'S
BOY.
>> THAT IS SO BEAUTIFUL!
I'M GOING TO HUG YOU, BOY.
HAPPY MOTHER'S DAY, SWEETHEART.
>> THANK YOU.
>> I LOVE YOU, MOM.
>> HAPPY MOTHER'S DAY.
>> THANK YOU.
>> VERY MUCH.
>> Larry: LAVELL CRAWFORD,
EVERYONE.